pour en parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors vous allez nous aider à y
voir un peu plus clair
la région séparatiste du haut karabagh
quels enjeux représente-t-elle bah
écoutez tout simplement la guerre et la
paix dans le caucase du sud
c'est une véritable bombe à retardement
que nous avons pris l'habitude d'appeler
depuis des années un conflit gelé mais
un conflit les gelées à un moment donné
photographiant un rapport de forces
c'est ce rapport de force peut se
modifier dans le temps et c'est
probablement ce qui est arrivé en effet
le l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan ont
commencé à être en conflit à la fin de
l'époque soviétique en mai en 1988 ce
conflit a duré jusqu'en 1994 donc on
était à l'époque de la russie et la
russie a réussi à négocier à un cessez
le feu en faisant une médiation dans
cette médiation
l'arménie a gagné à peu près 30% du sol
un verbe et janet et maintenant c'est
l'armée arménienne qui composeront serre
par sept partis y compris le nagorny
karabakh me gorny karabakh c'est quoi et
bien c'est un territoire dans lequel
vivent 150000 personnes qui sont pour la
plupart arménien en tout cas ils sont de
religion chrétienne et obéissent au
catholicos arménien et à plusieurs
reprises ils ont voulu être rattachés à
l'arménie en réalité pendant cette
guerre dont on vient de parler de 88 94
ils ont pris l'initiative de se déclarer
unilatéralement et les pandores
indépendance reconnue par personne pas
même par l'arménie d'ailleurs donc on a
là une situation qui a duré
jul en 94 part ce cessez le feu mais il
ya en effet un groupe de minsk dont on
vient de parler qui sous l'égide de
l'ouest c'est eux
coprésidé par la russie par les états
unis par la france était supposé
conduire des négociations
ces négociations n'ont pas abouti et il
ya eu et puis uniquement des reprises du
conflit en 2016 et puis maintenant
depuis juillet et ce week-end dans des
conditions assez dramatique
alors il est possible en effet que en
laissant les conflits gelés trop
longtemps dans la dans leur état initial
et bien au bout de 26 ans et ne
correspondent plus aux rapports de force
c'est ça qui est inquiétant parce que
l'azerbaïdjan est un pays ayant de
fortes ressources pétrolières s'est
beaucoup enrichi a augmenté
considérablement son budget militaire
aujourd'hui le budget militaire de
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est à peu près l'équivalent de la
totalité du budget annuel de l'arménie
donc un petit peu une disparité le
rapport de forces est bien entendu cette
situation est préoccupante
l'azerbaïdjan cherche à chaque fois a
grignoté une partie du contrôle du
territoire contrôlé par par l'arménie
dont je faisais en quelques mots la
russie évoqué comme médiateur mais
concrètement qu'elles roulent peut-elle
jouer
alors comme on vient de le dire la
turquie soutien à l'azerbaïdjan qui
appartient à la zone culturelle
turcophones et la russie a de bons
rapports avec les deux pays par
conséquent elle est tout désigné pour
mener une médiation en effet cela dit
l'arménie appartient aussi à
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective et se considère donc comme
défendue par la russie qui d'ailleurs a
une base militaire en arménie la russie
demande qu'il y à un cessez le feu tout
le monde ment qu'il ya un cessez le feu
et c'est en effet certainement la chose
à plusieurs jantes mais il faudrait que
le groupe de minsk
encore une fois coprésidé par la russie
mais aussi par les etats-unis et par la
france
reprenne son bâton de pèlerin pour
négocier un véritable accord merci
beaucoup
claude blanche maison poe votre
expertise je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales